what's going on guys this is rob and
will poulter has apparently been cast as
adam warlock in the mcu and this is huge
we know adam warlock was a character
who's going to appear in the mc we've
known that since the end of guardians 2
right when aisha had basically created
the perfect person and said she was
going to name him adam so we kind of
knew okay cool adam warlock showing up i
still think it's a little interesting
that adam warlock was basically created
by an alien race as opposed to humanity
but that's more the comic book fan of me
coming out right like in the comics adam
warlock was created by a group called
the enclave who were basically like
these scientists that wanted to dominate
the world through technological means
scientific means ultimately they were
defeated by the fantastic four and adam
warlock escaped into space but the cool
thing is that we're gonna get to see him
that's really the most important thing
out of all of this regardless of how
he's created now undoubtedly the
question people are most likely going to
ask is how powerful is this guy right
how powerful is adam warlock and in
truth we'll probably do an actual
origins and powers video on him once we
get closer to what most likely will be
guardians 3 or when popularity just
really ticks off or if this video turns
out to be just like hugely popular the
thing here is that people will likely
compare adam warlock to thanos and i
think a lot of that's just because of
the fact that thanos is kind of like the
standard at the moment with regards to
like the powerful nature of characters
that are out there i think that will be
the standard until eternals comes out
and then i think a lot of people are
going to say okay so like the celestials
are the new ceiling who's more powerful
than them and you could pretty much say
nobody
no one will really be on par with the
power of the celestials save for like
galactus right or like somebody more
powerful than them obviously thanos with
the infinity gauntlet maybe kane the
conqueror but getting back on topic here
the thing about adam warlock is you
can't really compare him to thanos
because adam warlock was never really
designed to be on par with the power of
thanos so honestly yes thanos was
stronger than adam warlock the
importance of adam warlock is he's more
of like a i would say kind of one part
spiritual one part prophet we always
refer to him as space jesus in the comic
book community because quite literally
there was the counter-earth story which
is when he really began to become
popular marvel comics he's basically
sent to a alternate version of earth
that orbits the sun and was created by
the high evolutionary i know it's weird
comic book logic but basically he faced
off this guy called the man beast who
was designed to be a kind of comic book
allegory for satan and then
basically adam warlock was crucified
and then he died and then he came back
and he's basically been space jesus ever
since right whenever he dies he goes
through his cocoon and then kind of
heals and then re-emerges at a future
point in time so he's not really
designed to be on par with thanos in
terms of power but adam warlock is going
to be one of the most powerful
characters that you will have seen in
the entirety of the marvel cinematic
universe up to this point now i still
stand by the idea that adam warlock is
going to appear at the very end of thor
for love and thunder i still think
that's going to be the case and the
question is why because when adam
warlock first encountered thor it was
when he basically kidnapped his love
interest sif and then tried to marry her
now a lot of this was because of the
fact that adam warlock was very very
primitive he didn't really understand
the kind of social nuances and social
norms that existed seemingly across the
universe but especially in relation to
somebody like thor who although he's not
really human has basically adopted human
customs and so we as humanity kind of
recognize snatching a person up and then
trying to force them to marry you
is kind of outside the social norms it's
not really what you do
you normally just get down on one knee
after having been in a relationship for
a long time ask them to marry you and
pray to god they say yes
that's kind of the social norm when it
comes to the idea of like marriage
proposal that sort of thing and so this
led to a fight between adam warlock and
thor now in reality this was just
designed to give us a depiction of how
powerful adam warlock was in relation to
thor but that's kind of a hallmark of
adam warlock's character when you see
him facing off against different
characters in the early appearances in
comics it was designed to showcase how
powerful he was against some of marvel's
biggest heavy hitters and that'd be a
great way to showcase how powerful adam
warlock is by having him basically show
up beat the hell out of thor snatch up
whoever his love interest would be which
is most likely going to be valkyrie and
then kidnapper and race off because that
sets the entire plot for guardians of
the galaxy 3. because the big question
you have to ask here is if adam warlock
shows up in guardians of the galaxy 3
what's his motivation going to be what's
the point of going after adam warlock is
he just like raising a world because he
doesn't fully understand what he's
supposed to be doing he doesn't really
understand the role he plays was he
trained by the sovereign to be a villain
which is a little weird because the
sovereign in themselves are not
necessarily villainous right it's not
like they're a race of thanos's then i
thanos's what's the plural of thanos
it's not like they're a race of
thanos-like beings that are just
hell-bent on conquering everything in
existence by and large they're kind of
like just really advanced and it's like
you stay away we stay away and
everything's cool right so there really
doesn't seem to be any motivation for
why adam warlock would do anything that
was villainous on such a level that
would require the guardians of the
galaxy to intervene and act in the first
place and so having some situation as
thin as the plot really is for being
honest with ourselves which is
kidnapping the love interest of thor
racing off to some other part of of the
galaxy or the universe the guardians of
the galaxy and thor hop pursuit which
leads to a big conflict in guardians 3
seems to kind of make sense the biggest
problem you have with that is
how do you make a plot like that last
for two hours
a two-hour long fight because one guy
kidnapped another dude's girl i mean
that's then right so i'm sure james gunn
will come up with something great i'm
sure he'll do something fantastic with
regards to the plot of adam warlock and
him being some measure of a villain and
then facing off against the guardians
the other thing about this is that adam
warlock may not be a villain at all
right i mean maybe that he's just one of
these guys that it's kind of an initial
fight like what you'll see between the
eternals and the deviants and then like
the actual threat is out there somewhere
and they basically have to team up to
defeat that threat i'm curious to see
what they do because adam warlock's
capable he's powerful but he's not
ridiculously op in relation to the rest
of the mcu he's pretty high up there but
i'm always kind of curious to see what
things they'll come up with right james
gunn is nothing if not just highly
imaginative with regarding the plots and
things like that that he makes for the
movies that he directs so i'm curious to
see where things are going to go but
with that being said guys yeah will
poulton looks like he's going to be cast
out of more like kind of a funny thing
we never talked about why
what evidence do we have for this claim
okay so here's the thing usually
whenever it is that somebody tweets out
a roommate or james gun says hey james
gunn this person is rumored to be cast
as this character in this movie that
you're gonna be making which might have
something to do with the mcu might have
nothing to do with the mcu the thing is
that james gunn usually comes back with
a quickness and is like no that's not
gonna happen right just shoots it down
super fast somebody basically took this
rumor they retweeted it to james gunn
and said hey man so like will poulton is
apparently cast as adam warlock in the
mcu it's been qriket trips dead silence
and people are taking that as an
admission by james gunn that will
poulton is going to be cast as adam
warlock so sure i guess the evidence is
kind of flimsy but given the track
record of james gunn it kind of makes
sense the other evidence surrounding
this is even flimsier right the fact
that will poulton dropped out of the one
billion dollar project that amazon had
for lord of the rings due to contractual
obligations or other deals basically he
stood a better chance of having his
profile raised possibly making more
money for his individual contributions
and whatever future project he's doing
there's nothing about that that
indicates the mcu
i will say the mcu is highly popular and
i will say that what it looks like in
hollywood is everybody's chomping at the
chance to have a role in the mcu because
it's basically just the popular thing to
do at the moment but outside of that
there's nothing to indicate that will
poulton left lord of the rings from
amazon to be part of adam warlock in the
emcee right so the evidence is a little
scant there's not a whole lot to go on
here but in all honesty he seems like
the perfect guy to play the character so
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end let me know what
you all think down in the comments
section about will poulton playing adam
warlock and are you guys excited to see
adam warlock in the mcu thank you guys
for watching and i'll catch you all
later
peace